cheesegrater is back big time hey what's
up guys mkbhd here yes I brought an iMac
pro with me to the hotel room yes I'm
out here at WWDC in California and yes
today Apple did finally unveil a reveal
the new design for the 2019 Mac Pro the
cheese grater it's finally upon us so I
finally know what it looks like we
finally know what it's made of we
finally know what it costs kinda we
finally know what it's capable of so
this video is all of those things in one
place plus some personal thoughts of
mine also this shirt is a new one in the
mkbhd shop I'll have a link below the
like button if you want to check it out
it is back everything's on sale
including all the other stuff shameless
plug it's gonna be once every two months
that we do these drops now so first two
weeks of this month we have this stuff
on sale and get it if you want it all
right so the Mac Pro I'm gonna be honest
it felt kind of like the Tesla 2020
Roadster announcement when they went
through these specs because they're just
absolutely ridiculous and it ships this
fall so it's coming out before the
Roadster but let me just start with the
specs so the CPU will be anywhere from
an 8 core to a 28 core Intel Xeon there
are 12 DIMM slots for up to 1.5
terabytes of RAM I don't know if you got
that I'm gonna just say that one more
time just so you can digest it you can
fill all 12 dims with 20 900 megahertz
memory for 1.5 terabytes of RAM and then
it starts with one GPU an AMD Radeon pro
5 ATX and can go all the way up to 4 AMD
Radeon Pro Vega two GPUs which is nuts
no word on NVIDIA GPUs it has eight PCI
slots for full size and then for
half-size up to 4 terabytes of SSD
storage and a 1400 watt power supply so
by the numbers on paper of course we can
tell it's extremely high-end and then
the name of the game really is Headroom
here especially with that 1400 watt
power supply so you're giving yourself
room to grow into adding components to
it down the road as you upgrade it you
know like a normal PC and it's just
putting down silly
members at least promising them anyway
so Apple's website is covered in crazy
outrageous claims of performance over
not just the old Mac Pro but over the 18
core I'm a pro that I use now which is
already really fast so I'll drop the
link to this of course below the like
button also and then the design of
course that's what people are talking
about the most and that's what we're
kind of waiting to see and it's kind of
fascinating in a bunch of ways do you
know what trep trypophobia is with the
holes I don't know about you but this
gets like awkwardly close to that I'm
just gonna throw that out there but
obviously the main comparison is to a
cheese grater which is the same as that
previous Mac Pro that came before the
trash can but I'll take the cheese
grater over a trash can any day so this
new cheese grater is about the size of I
guess a normal mid-sized Tower it's
definitely not as big as the old cheese
grater but it's way bigger than the
trashcan thankfully and it's all metal
as you can see those arcs across the top
are handles and there's a third handle
in the middle that you can twist and
then pull the entire show off as
demonstrated many times both on their
website and by this sweet augmented
reality demo they were doing and that
gets you full access to everything
there's two Thunderbolt ports at the top
along with the power button at the top
and an LED light and the back is just
all your outputs from all those PCI
slots so that includes the Apple one
that's built-in which gives you the
headphone jack
two full-size USB ports and two
Thunderbolt so clearly there's a lot
going on with the design of this tower
but even on the inside I think it's just
as interesting as the outside so there's
a bunch of modules that will be included
to fit into those many PCI slots and
there were Apple calls MPX modules so
there's a graphics card MPX module for
example that they're putting the GPUs
into and that gives you thunderbolt and
HDMI out and then third parties can also
all chip in and make their own MPX
modules each one of which can take up to
500 watts of power so promise for
example the company that makes that huge
96 terabyte raid array of hard drives on
my desk they've promised to make a small
MPC module that has a huge amount of
hard drives in it for the inside of the
Mac Pro so you can put these things
inside the computer and there's another
one Apple makes called the afterburner
card which is essentially just for video
encoding and video editing processing so
it can
take a lot of the work of processing pro
res and pro res raw off of your CPU and
we'll dedicate it on to that card by
itself which is amazing for people who
use those codecs and is great for video
editing so these modules are really
powerful and that is the kind of
modularity people were asking for and
waiting for for so long having all those
PCI slots to add into there are three
huge fans on the front taking advantage
of that cheesegrater design and another
blower in the back so you've constant
air flow going through the whole thing
but they've said it can be quite enough
to be on your desk or next to you and
not be a problem so yeah it's just it's
pretty much a rebuild from the ground up
like we've wanted the price so the face
line for this Mac Pro is gonna start at
six thousand dollars now the thing to
remember about pricing like actual pro
grade equipment like the word pro I
think is is sort of overused you know
one plus seven Pro what does that really
mean iPad pro Mir pro but really for
actual professional-grade equipment that
stuff is very expensive and it's clearly
not for everyone
this new Mac Pro is of course a creative
tool but no amount of money you spend on
a creative tool will make you better at
creating I think we all know this but it
will help with things like quality
control and of course making things
faster which is what professionals pay a
lot of money for and actually that
brings us conveniently to the one
accessory the one other piece of
hardware that launched alongside the Mac
Pro which is the new Pro display this
new screen is called the Apple Pro
display XDR and XDR stands for extreme
dynamic range and this thing is again a
monster on the spec sheet if you know
anything about the world of pro displays
and reference monitors or even if you
don't it's a 32 inch 6k HDR display it's
an LCD that gets up to 1600 nits of peak
brightness and has a million to 1
contrast ratio which is excellent for an
LCD and as you can see ultra thin bezels
and it'll come in a glossy version or
this fancy nano etched glass which is
matte instead and that's of course
extremely color accurate of course the
actual hands-on and and being able to
put our own content on it is extremely
limited at events like this so I haven't
seen my own videos on it so it's hard
for me to tell exactly how good it is
but Apple draws a lot of compare
instead that 35 $45,000 reference
monitors that are used in these actual
editing houses that are making movies
and things like that the sustained 1000
nits of brightness is definitely the
hardest part that takes a lot of power
and a lot of cooling to get something
like this to not overheat so that's why
you see the cheese grater ventilation in
the back of the monitor matching the Mac
Pro and there's even a fan in the back
constantly spinning that you can't hear
but it's necessary starting price for
this monitor five thousand dollars and
to get the Nano Edge 2 glass version
that has the matte finish
that's another thousand bucks so if you
want that one it's six thousand dollars
and then with the super thin bezels
there's no camera built-in so that's
sold separately
oh yeah and so is the stand so the stand
which is all-metal it swivels and tilts
and height adjusts and can even rotate
into portrait mode it's actually a
pretty excellent stand it's not included
in the monitors $5,000 price that's an
extra $1000 for that metal stand now
that is a really easy thing to make fun
of it for I would do the same thing
mostly because the way they announced it
on stage was terrible they gave like the
prices of $5,000 or $6,000 for the stand
why would you do it like that the truth
is a lot of people doing professional
video editing and things like that are
using these displays that are mounted in
place and they have stands already so
when the upgrade displays they take them
out and put them in the same place and
they don't need to buy new mounts and
new stands for them so these people buy
monitors with no displays all the time
but you and me and people watching WWDC
and most normal people just think of a
monitor and a stand as together so I
guess what they should have said was
this is a six thousand dollar monitor
but if you want to buy it without the
stand it's a thousand bucks off 5k still
expensive obviously and that's gonna
look insane if you put it on the shelf
next to other similar monitors and Best
Buy or something but it can look like a
bargain when you're shopping it against
the 40,000 dollar reference monitors
that it's actually competing against
with pro so anyway all in all there's no
denying these two pieces of gear are
extremely high-end and extremely
expensive like this is not something
most people
get just like the previous MacPro but
damn like I you know I was we've been
waiting for this for a while and they've
made a lot of improvements to it I mean
especially on paper and just in the
design that we've been waiting for for a
long time for the Mac Pro it's coming
out in the fall so I don't know probably
the end of the fall but I'm actually
really looking forward to it and looking
forward to seeing how it'll fit into my
workflow of course that afterburner card
isn't gonna do our 3d transcoding it'll
do pro res and pro res Raw but I might
have to mess around with that a little
bit more all this stuff depends on once
I finally get it on my desk I'm also a
little terrified about how much it will
end up costing we should probably place
bets on like how much them maxed out
highest end config will cost I mean by
the time you add a terabyte and a half
of RAM a 28 core Xeon even the optional
little wheels that you can put on the
bottom this thing is probably gonna go
I'm gonna say I'm gonna say $40,000 even
that's my guess but the whole point is
you don't have to buy the highest end
one like you had to with the iMac pro
you buy whatever tier you need now and
you can upgrade it in the future and
that's the Mac Pro we've been waiting
for so I'll take the cheese grater over
the trash can any day either way let me
know if you guys think there's been a
quick first impressions video thanks for
watching I catch you guys in the next
one peace
[Music]